as a muslim i found something very
interesting as
megan was walking with uh
oprah and they're going there she said
something very interesting and it
reminded me of something
from the prophetic tradition busy with
what people think look well she said
that whole big thing and the weather
thing
that's for the world
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
the website is in the description link
below you can also use a discount code
salam 10 for 10 of their products
don't forget to like share and subscribe
to your brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys are well inshallah
well as a muslim i'm going to be
reacting to the whole
the royal family fiasco now i found
something very interesting as i was
watching this video
um of oprah winfrey um interviewing uh
megan
now i was watching this with my wife
last night um and my in-laws
and we just wanted to hear out because i
heard that you know it's like some kind
of racism happen but that's not what i'm
going to touch upon
as a muslim i found something very
interesting as megan
was walking with uh oprah
to the chick uh what's it called the
archie's chick in yeah okay so basically
archie is their first child
and they're going there this is
something very interesting and it
reminded me of something
from the prophetic tradition and as
muslims uh when it comes to marriage and
i found it very
very interesting so here's the video we
can't watch the video obviously for
copyright but you can hopefully with the
audio we don't get copyrighted
uh we're just going to watch that um and
i might have to stop it every now and
then just
due to copyright uh but yeah let's just
get straight into it uh hopefully if you
guys want to watch the fourth thing go
to itv hub
and watch it there so here we go design
a house here
archie's chicken oh how cute is that
she's always wearing a chicken but you
know i just love rescuing
so this is a part of your new life what
are you most excited about
what are you most excited about in the
new life what are you most excited
i think just being able to live
authentically
that's interesting uh as someone that
um you know come from the royal family
you know for her to express that she
just wants to live
authentically this is very important
because she was expressing how she would
have to fake for the cameras when
they're on smiling and all the stuff
she's going through suicidal thoughts
but anyways that's very interesting
right like this kind of stuff it's so
it's so basic but it's really fulfilling
and just getting back down to basics i
mean i was thinking about it even our
web
wow that's amazing getting back down to
basis we all want to live that high
famous you know want to be famous
everyone knows us etc we do not see the
dark side to it
until you live it and then you realize
for yourself um here
is where the crux of the matter was for
us muslims
and for those who non-muslims are
watching because of this whole thing um
look what she says about her marriage
about her wedding day i was thinking
about it even our wedding
you know three days before our wedding
we got married
no one knows that but we called the
archbishop and we just said look this
three days before our wedding we got
married this is a
prophetic tradition yeah and the
christian tradition is usually
you get married um you know when this
whole big wedding thing happens etc
uh islamically we get married with
something called nikah
so that is when the marriage actually
happens the
lima which she's talking about after
which is the whole big celebration and
all that kind of stuff
and to announce the marriage which is
very important in islam um so it's not
keeping hidden you know because a lot of
men you know
go you know have side tricks and
mistresses and girlfriends and then try
to keep a hidden
against islam but you have to announce
it um it's very
important so the thing is um and she
goes she rang the archbishop
which is we can call about an imam which
is an imam basically
and said look you know we just want
something simple
let's carry on watching look what she
says dang the spectacle is for the world
but we want our union between us so like
the vows that we have framed in our room
were
just the two of us in our backyard with
the archbishop of canterbury and
and that was the piece that through us
that is amazing that is so amazing that
as muslims there is a lesson to be
learnt from that because sadly today's
time as muslims we are too busy with
what people think look
well she said that whole big thing and
the weather thing that's for the world
that's not for us that's very
interesting because
at today's age a lot of people want to
prove things to others
yeah it might be your haters you know
you want to prove to them yeah look i
got married or whatever it may be here
family members whatever it may be you
are too busy and occupied to prove
things to others and this makes you
unhappy
when i was not a muslim and i came to
islam before that i was very
the same not maybe not with marriage but
i was too busy proving myself to others
a variety of things
and i was like am i really doing this
for myself no i'm doing it for others
to get their approval who the hell are
they you know without you respect yeah
why do i need to prove myself to them
with the things that i'm doing
i should do what i want to do and it's
so interesting that it was just her
uh her husband-to-be and the archbishop
you know
now in islam obviously the female needs
a guardian yeah
a male member uh to be that at the nikah
and two witnesses yeah
but still it resonates you can't try to
say and the reason for the guardian is
obviously
um it's there to protect the rights of a
woman uh against predators you know
in any way shape or form predators come
from diff different kind of form they
don't come looking evil there could be
people that have an agenda so a man
knows a man that's why
islam god almighty has legislated a man
to be the guardian of the woman
and not that she's not capable of of
course you can choose somebody that she
likes
but for the man to interrogate that
interrogate the guy and to make sure
that he's not after the wrong things
is the duty of a man that's why allah
says they are the protectors and
maintainers of a
woman alhamdulillah so the thing is i
found that very beautiful i found it
really amazing
and it's a reminder to us as muslims
looking at that two christian couple
calling the archbishop
um um i don't know which archbishop
maybe archer of canterbury i don't know
yeah
i hear that a lot yeah they contacted
him and said we want to make this simple
me and
me and harry and we want to get married
i found that really amazing i genuinely
found it amazing
and coming from a christian couple i
think as muslims
we should learn a lesson from that
brothers and sisters
um it's very very important for us to
acknowledge this
and um re-implement this sunnah because
the prophet peace be upon him
this is how it was having small simple
weddings has barakah
when you make things complicated this is
where zinna comes into it
other elements why you know because you
want to have a big wedding and the guy
has to
you know make sure he saved that 20 30
40 grand and men today are thinking you
know what forget that mate
i'm just gonna go and get what i can
have in a marriage
intimacy and other stuff without doing
all of that and that is the reason why a
lot of people are moving away from the
concept of marriage and falling into sin
and that is the reason why the prophet
peace be upon him said if a righteous
man comes to ask for your daughter's
hand
and you reject there will be fitna
trials in the land
uh and subhanallah it reminds me i don't
know if it might have been a fan i can't
remember but one of the companions came
to the prophet peace be upon him and it
seemed very like it's come from a place
of celebration
and the prophecy was on peace people
said like what happened it's like i got
married
not it's so not not how fast and the cow
was done because usually the companies
would invite the prophet
but it happened so fast you know
and not like today that always made so
difficult and in five minutes time
two people can get married yeah that's
how it takes that's how long it takes
for the uh for it to happen it's as far
as a few words i said
you accept marrying her etc and the
wedding is done
that's how it should be and we've made
it so hard for ourselves so watching the
megan and harry
interview i know it wasn't about this it
was more of a bigger picture i might do
a reaction
to the whole what she went through the
racism etc um
but i just wanted to do this video to
convey to you guys
as muslims for us to go back to the
tradition of this uh the prophetic
tradition
to keep things simple what a beautiful
example from harry
and megan and we can learn a lesson from
that to keep things
simple any ma'am um
you're you like that person that person
likes you your guardian is there
not none of this bulky bloody skype
marriages etc here
okay your guardian is that alhamdulillah
is done
alhamdulillah you are away from zina and
the prophet peace be upon him the
companion said this and i'll end on this
now
that they said all messenger of allah is
it true that we get rewarded by having
intimacy with our partners
or you know a wife's having intimacy
with her husband husband with a wife
he said of course you do just as you
incur a major sin when you come in does
it not
you get a good deed when you do the
halal and they found that amazing
so uh zina in a nutshell means having
sex outside of marriage
so brothers and sisters uh that's about
it i just wanted to share that video
with you guys i found it very
fascinating you can watch the whole
interview
uh but i think that's it i don't think
they see anything else let's see
just the three of us that's it guys
until next time assalamualaikum
warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh